- I look like Brooke Shields.
Oh shit.
(theme music)
- For this challenge,
since we only have two dudes
of the Test Friends,
we're inviting along our friend, Curly.
- I've been recruited
to join the Test Friends.
- I know the basics of make-up,
essential like the words
foundation--
- I don't really know
the difference between
concealer or cover up.
- So we got the whole week to
sort of figure this out
and go through a trial and error process.
And then, Friday we
have the holiday party,
which I think Ryan and
Curly sort of forgot about.
- Aw, fuck! (laughs)
- The days leading up to the holiday party
will let me hone my craft.
- Make-up,
that's what we're doing now, I guess.
- We're here at the mecca of make-up.
- [Shane] None of us have
any experience with this.
- It's easy.
- It's easy?
- Okay.
- "Voo-doo prince",
"Man-scaper",
"Bush Master",
that's me!
- [Shane and Curly] Bush master.
- [Shane] You're the bush master?
(laughs)
- Bush master, butt plugs.
- Where did the butt plug come in?
- That pink thing looks like a butt plug.
How could I know about butt plugs?
- Don't put that in my
face after you say that!
- Butt plug.
- Get in here.
- Is there like a thing
that we could do
to fill in my beard?
- Yes, we can do that too.
- Let's do it!
- [Ryan] Wait, I don't
see what's happening.
- It's beauty.
That's what's happening.
- [Ryan] Oh, shit.
- [Shane] That is incredible.
(snaps)
- Daddy wants, daddy want that too.
- [Shane] Your eyebrows get pretty thin
on the sides though.
It's gonna look like
someone just drew
(overlapping talking and laughing)
- [Shane] So just sort
of gunks up the hair
that's already there.
- [Henry] Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, that was definitely darker.
- [Henry] Yeah.
- Should I fill in the other eyebrow?
- [Shane] Oh, come on!
I would like to see you
walk around like this
- Go ahead and do it.
I bet you can do it yourself.
- Oh, shit.
- Okay, a little heavy.
A little heavy in the wrong spots, too.
- [Shane] A little heavy, buddy.
- I got that Marty's Chris Hazy look now.
- [Ryan] Do you feel fresh?
- No.
(laughs)
- There is something different about it.
- It being my face?
- [Ryan] The skin tone's
all one color now.
- You know, if I get up real close,
it looks like the Utah salt flats.
- Whoa, you're right.
There's a little eggshell-ish
stuff going on there.
- Yeah.
- [Henry] Nice, so let's go down to Kayla
and get you checked out.
- [Shane] Great!
- Cool.
- Okay.
- I'm so happy.
- This is day one.
It's pretty early right now.
- [Voiceover] It's 8:15.
- I know but right now,
I normally would be asleep
and I'm not asleep.
- Just gonna wing this.
- I'm not nervous
bacause I've secretly have been wearing it
all weekend anyways.
- I might ask my girlfriend for help
one hundred percent.
She works in an office.
She needs the make-up.
She doesn't need the make-up (laughs)
- This is so fun.
- This is silly.
- [Shane] It was very reassuring
to know that,
well I look like shit,
but 10 minutes from now,
I'm gonna look like Ryan Seacrest.
I have a tiny little zit
popping up over here.
Where'd it go?
You can't even tell.
- I look dead.
- No you don't.
Why do you look dead?
- Because my face is all one tone
and it only happens when you're dead.
- So what I do is I put the beard on.
Try not to put too much.
- Holy cow!
Those are brows.
- I don't know if I'm doing it right.
I just go like (gagging).
- And I'm just gonna,
okay, there's a lot.
- I don't think we need to put anymore on.
- Guess that's what I'm
gonna look like today.
- Such beauty.
I did try out different techniques.
In the beginning, like I said,
I was filling in my eyebrows
a little bit too much,
and Mallory noticed it.
- They look like one caterpillar.
(laughs)
- And it's a little furry.
But still sexy.
- [Shane] There was one morning
where I was running
a little late
and I had no time to do it.
Am I gonna go into work
looking like this though?
No.
This is trash.
There's a new standard now
and I have to adhere to it.
So I'm going to have to apply my make-up
in the Uber car that is arriving shortly.
The man in front didn't
really give me weird looks.
He seemed cool with it.
- [Ryan] People at work
did say I looked "glowing".
- The boys are wearing make-up
and it's weirding me out
how lovely they look.
They look beautiful!
- [Ryan] I think she was just being nice.
She knew what was going on.
I don't know if it was a legit compliment.
I'm not gonna take it as that.
- My beautiful boys!
(laughs)
- It only took my 30 minutes to do this.
- Today is our holiday party
and the last day that we will
have to be wearing make-up.
- Kind of gotta make sure
that my make-ups like
not half-assed today.
- It was fun knowing
that I had this little
extra fancy step to do
and that I was gonna be a little fancy man
going to the party
with these little fancy make-up.
- In the midst of the
chaos of the holiday party,
we all somehow got together
and took a picture.
- [Curly] Everybody looked great.
Shane's skin looks flawless.
Ryan, I couldn't even tell
actually, was wearing make-up.
- [Ryan] We were all pretty out of it.
But it was a good time.
I think we came out with a solid
photo booth picture.
- [Curly] I think there
is a stigma behind make-up
but I think that
there's something very empowering
about putting on a little bit of
war paint, if you will.
- I don't know.
I just think it's silly
that we live in this society
where people are kind of pressured
into looking a certain way everyday.
I don't really think that's fair
or right.
- I'm not gonna wear it again probably.
But I can certainly see the advantages.
I didn't really feel like I was ever
enhancing my beauty in any way.
It was just kind of damage control.
- Make-up is dope.
You can hide behind it.
You can enhance it.
It'll give you a little
bit more confidence.
It might take some away.
- I now know what it's like
to have to do this every morning
and it's not fun.
- Look at me.
This is a success story.
Kind of.
A little pale.
- [Ryan] I could sit here all day.
- [Curly] Also, you guys don't know
where those brushes have been.
- I mean, it's just on
other peoples' faces.
It's not like someone's
brushing their ass cheeks over here.